Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hinter dir ein dreiköpfiger Affe.
So dumm bin ich nicht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 300. Was haben wir überhaupt? 10, 11?
11.
Keine Ahnung. Ja.
Aber letztes auf jeden Fall.
311 live vom Chaos Communication Camp in Mildenberg.
Im Zigeleipack in Mildenberg?
Genau. Und nicht nur live, sondern auch on stage, nämlich hier im Three-Headed Monkey.
Und es sind ganz viele Gäste da. Hallo, herzlich willkommen.
Wir haben uns zum Ziel gesetzt, nicht zu viel über das Camp zu reden,
aber weil Tim ja noch eine weitere Freakshow hier macht am Freitag.
Samstag.
Samstag. Samstagabend hier. Da wird dann mehrere Stunden über das Camp geredet
und die Gäste kommen danach.
Aber ich will trotzdem mal ganz kurz meine Begeisterung hier für dieses Three-Headed
Monkey Village aussprechen.
Die Älteren von euch erinnern sich an das Computerspiel Monkey Island,
was ja hier auch für diejenigen, für die der Podcast zu langweilig ist,
hier im Playthrough laufen läuft. Wir kennen das ja alle auswendig.
Also bitte, wenn da irgendwie hinten was Falsches passiert, nicht die Lösungen
reinrufen. Wir versuchen uns hier zu konzentrieren.
Aber das THM ist, ja, finde ich tatsächlich wirklich beeindruckende Aktion von Entropia, CCCB,
Cardus und Vollgas Crew mit eigenem Piratenschiff und die Mitglieder des Three-Eyed-Monkey-Village
rennen auch alle in Piraten,
Kleidung rum und irgendwie freut mich das immer sehr zu sehen,
was so der CCCB und die anderen Clubs Entropia, Kados,
Vollgas Crew hier so einfach mal in ihrer Freizeit aufbauen und da dürft ihr
gerne einmal für ganz laut applaudieren.
Ja, auch noch erwähnenswert ist das Hacker-Bastel des diesjährigen Camps,
was so ein bisschen in den Mittelpunkt gerückt ist, weil man es ja gleich vorbestellen
konnte, das Cardio-Batch.
Wer von euch hat sein Cardio-Batch dabei? Oh, okay.
Auflösung, einige.
Und die leuchten auch schon, okay, ihr habt alle grün, also grün heißt ansprechbar, ne?
Ansprechbar. Also die Herzdaten erlauben sozusagen, dass man sie ansprechen
darf. Wenn dich irgendjemand zutextet.
Dann drückst du auf rot und dann sagst du, hier, klopf rot. Das ist gut.
Das gefällt mir sehr gut. Das ist hervorragend.
Auch wieder ein geiles Projekt kommt, wie eigentlich jetzt zumindest in den
letzten drei Camps immer von den Münchnern so.
Schneider, Lila, Fisch, Ole, Seck, die ganze Münchner. Die sind nicht aufzuhalten.
Der Münchner CCCB, nein, sorry.
Das hast du gesagt. Das ist mir so rausgekommen. Das habe ich nicht gesagt, zumindest nicht laut.
Mit EKG und Stresssensor. Wer hat schon eine EKG-Warnung bekommen von seinem
Cardio-Batch? Niemand.
Dann müssen wir daran arbeiten.
Ich habe heute einen Anruf bekommen auf meinem Deck-Telefon und es erreicht
nämlich eine Durchsage des Wok at Pok, oder Pok at Wok Also es gibt ja das Waffel-Operation-Center.
Die arbeiten mit, wie heißt das, waffelfähigen Teig, haben die.
Und waffelfähige Teigprodukte, genau. Und die betreiben damit regen,
kostenfreien Handel mit Waffeln.
Und ich war dann auch beim Waffelhändler.
Und genau, das POC hat sich da etwas gebaut, weil die gesehen haben,
dass irgendwie der Umsatz nicht stark genug war oder das Spendenaufkommen nicht hoch genug.
Und dann hat das POG gesagt, wir haben ja eh nichts zu tun, weil unsere Infrastruktur
ja einfach läuft, also das Phone-Operation-Center, wir machen mal Waffeln,
bis der Teig alle ist und haben sich dann, weil es sonst zu langweilig wäre,
so einen Buzzer gebaut, der neben dem Waffelding ist und jedes Mal,
wenn sie den Buzzer drücken,
macht die POG-Telefonanlage, wählt sich random zwei Nummern aus und informiert
die darüber, dass sie sich jetzt Waffeln abholen können.
Und daneben steht ein großer Bildschirm, wo Sie irgendwie auf dem Graf laufen
haben, Ihre WPM, die Waffe per Minute.
Und da arbeiten Sie natürlich auch am besten, bester Quality of Service,
die Sie irgendwie erreichen können.
Ja, POC sowieso immer Eisenhard dabei.
Morgen gibt es auch wieder ein Musikvideo-Release vom POC.
Das Musikvideo muss nur noch gedreht werden. Bei allen anderen würde man sagen,
seid ihr euch sicher, dass ihr das morgen releast?
Beim POG fragt man, schafft er das vor sechs?
Das, was ich auch sehr geil finde hier, was mir so aufgefallen ist,
das LOG, Logistics Operations Center.
Die hier die ganze Logistik irgendwie machen, alles, was hier hin und her gefahren werden muss,
die Einlagerungen und das irgendwie seit Anfang des Monats und immer mit irgendwie
cooler Laune, außer ihr rennt irgendwie in diesen Lagerbereich rein,
wenn das Radladerballett gerade im Gange ist, dann werden die auch mal grantig,
aber das ist auch wirklich einfach eine krasse Arbeit, höchste Quality of Service
mit höchster 5 von 5 Punkten, gute Laune, das ist auch echt ein Traum,
dem Team zuzuschauen, finde ich, muss ich echt sagen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall Applaus wert,
dieses Jahr in einer bemerkenswerten Doppelbelastung durch den Kongress,
also nicht nur das Lock, aber vor allem das Lock also ja.
Das sind glaube ich die, die am stärksten zu leiden haben unter zwei Groß-Events
im Jahr, also alle haben zu leiden Lock auch leidet doppelt.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch ein bisschen was vom Rock erzählen,
dem Radio Operations Center, weil ich bei denen hinten in der Werkstatt war,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich erzählen darf, was die da alles haben,
deswegen überspringen wir das kurz.
Das ist auf jeden Fall, also kann ich nur empfehlen. Sehr spannend,
was da noch so für andere Probleme gelöst werden.
Und ansonsten gibt es ja hier sowieso eine ganze Reihe undankbarer Aufgaben für Idealisten.
Sowas wie unvollständige Aufzählungen, Einlass, Bändchenkontrolle, Merch verkaufen.
Ja, irgendwie, was verkaufen wir irgendwie um die 5000 Textile gehen in den Verkauf.
Village Orga. Ja, wer von euch hat nicht die Village Orga angeschrien und gesagt,
ich will aber mehr Platz.
Das waren ein paar Leute, die sich das alles anhören mussten.
Camper Orga, ganz undankbare Aufgabe.
Ganz undankbare Aufgabe. Kommen dann so Leute mit dem Bus, wo hinten noch ein
Anhänger dran ist und meinen, das wäre eingespannt und wollen dann da parken,
während andere sich ärgern, dass sie für ihren kleinen VW-Bus,
also auch echt undankbar.
Und was wir ja dann immer so hören, sind eigentlich so diese Sätze,
warum habt ihr eigentlich nicht?
Und nächstes Mal müsst ihr mal.
Und übrigens, das sind die Sätze,
die C3 Post muss ich auch noch lobend erwähnen, stelle ich gerade fest.
Wow. Mit Stempel.
Was bei der Chaos Post übrigens vielleicht wenige von euch wissen.
Die Zustellung ist nicht... Oh, du hast einen Anruf vom C3-Wog-Featuring.
Ich glaube, du musst jetzt eine Waffel abholen.
Das war jetzt bestimmt random.
Soll ich das mal aufmachen hier? Ach, das ist schick. Totschick.
Ich gehe mal in Deckung, du hast bestimmt wieder eine Torte.
Nee, nee.
Kannst du noch irgendwas unterhalten sagen?
Ja, ich erzähle noch, bei der Chaos-Post könnt ihr nicht nur an Personen,
sondern auch an Personen bei Events zustellen.
Netzbuch-Logpolitik auch. Genau, sehr gut. Vielen herzlichen Dank.
Netzbuch-Logpolitik. Und hier ist noch was für die Influencer.
Für die Influencer. Bestimmt ein Grippemittel.
Bestimmt irgendwas. Das ist Es ist puschelig.
Wenn es puschelig ist, ist es bestimmt peinlich.
Ich versuche noch mal kurz zu erzählen. Ihr könnt mit der Chaos-Post an Leute
bei Events, ihr könnt also Post in die Zukunft senden.
Vergangenheit arbeiten sie noch dran, aber Zukunft geht schon. Was ist das?
Oh Linus, ey. Ja. Nein, pack das bitte wieder ein.
Also ich meine, man kann das schon noch mal erwähnen. Also Nippelklemmkunst,
das öffnet jetzt noch mal ganz andere Türen.
Du hattest da in irgendeiner Sendung mal nachgefragt, glaube ich.
Ist das wahr? Ja, danke. Wir sollen Ankündigungen wir sollen ankündigen,
haben wir aber schon angekündigt.
Die Privacy Week haben wir schon angekündigt. 21. bis 27.10. in Wien.
2019. Privacy Week im Volkskundemuseum. Mit ein paar Nippelklemmen kann man
sich jederzeit Werbung bei Logbuch Netzpolitik schaffen.
Das macht jetzt bestimmt Schuh lang.
Nach uns ist übrigens nach uns ist Markus Becke da dran mit 15 Jahre Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Ne, 15 Jahre Netzpolitik.org Entschuldigung, ich hatte hier diesen Aufkleber.
Es passiert übrigens tatsächlich sehr regelmäßig, dass Leute dort hinschreiben,
wenn sie Tim und mich erreichen wollen, aber auch umgekehrt.
Meistens so mit, warum habt ihr eigentlich nicht, nächstes Mal müsst ihr aber und übrigens Mails.
Das sagt man ja immer so leicht, aber ich finde ja, wenn Leute vom nächsten
Mal reden, ist das eigentlich schon ein dickes Lob.
Weil das bedeutet ja sozusagen, dass man überhaupt nicht anzweifelt.
Dass sie trotzdem nochmal kommen.
Ja, dass man das auch weiterhin tun sollte. Also ich gehöre ja auch immer so
ein bisschen zur Zukunftsabteilung und denke mir immer schon,
was man nächstes Mal machen sollte.
Da bin ich ein bisschen mitschuld, aber es ist immer nett gemeint.
Und da fährt mir nur ein, das haben wir wahrscheinlich schon 100 Mal erzählt,
aber früher, ich habe bei Netzpolitik auch mal gearbeitet, von 2010 bis 2011 ungefähr.
Und dann war 2011 das Camp und da hatte Tim die Idee für Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Und deswegen freue ich mich auch, dass wir das jetzt hier beim Camp machen.
Wer hätte das gedacht? Stimmt, das ist dann genau acht Jahre her dann sozusagen.
Ziemlich genau, ja. Happy Birthday.
Nee, die erste Sendung war etwas später.
Naja, aber es hat lange gedauert, bis wir dieses Gespräch auch mal wirklich
führen konnten, auf dieser Veranstaltung, weil immer ein Verstrahlter dazwischen
kam. Rennst du auf dem Camper rum und so.
Tim Britlaff muss noch mit mir reden. Wir haben nicht hingekriegt, aber nachher gemacht.
Ja, das waren die Einleitungen, glaube ich. Und damit wären wir beim ersten
Thema. Oder willst du auch noch was sagen?
Nö, aber man wird ja wohl noch mal was sagen dürfen.
Das wird Maaßen ja wohl noch sagen dürfen. Unsere ersten beiden Sendungsgäste
sind Johannes Filter und Markus Reuter. Da ist er.
Kommt her.
Markus, du hast den großen Platz. Johannes, du musst hier auf den Kuscheleckchen mit mir.
Ganz intim hier alles. Wir sind ganz unter uns.
So, funktioniert? Sagt mal was.
Hallo. Eins, zwei, drei.
Super, hallo, herzlich willkommen. Schön, dass ihr gekommen seid.
Ich habe festgestellt, du warst gerade schon auf der Bühne, ne?
Du hast quasi jetzt, warst du nicht zum Transparenzgesetz auch auf der Bühne gerade?
Ne, das war der Herr Semsrott.
Ich habe dich da auch gesehen, habe ich mir da.
Unterschriften gesammelt.
Ah, okay, ja genau, das wollten wir noch sagen, ne? Transparenzgesetz für Berlin,
wichtig, wollen wir gerne haben.
Ihr könnt dafür unterschreiben, müsst ihr auch. am besten immer direkt zu 5,
damit der Zettel wegkommt, weil ihr müsst da eure komplette Adresse draufschreiben.
Wer will schon seine Adresse hier auslegen?
Aber genau, das ist aber nicht Thema. Das Thema ist die Datenanalyse, die du gemacht hast.
Wir haben uns überlegt, wir reden erstmal nur über die Methodik und dann über
die Ergebnisse. Was hast du getan?
Also der Startpunkt war Hans-Georg Maaßen und seine Aktivitäten auf Twitter.
Und da habe ich angefangen, mir anzuschauen, okay, Okay, er haut so Tweets raus,
dann habe ich mir angesehen, okay, er hat 21.000 Follower und dann gesehen,
welche Leute von diesen 21.000 Followern retweeten ihn und wenn die Hans-Georg
Maaßen retweeten, was retweeten die sonst noch so?
Das war so der Startpunkt der Analyse.
Und die Daten hast du wie bekommen?
Über die Twitter-API.
Und das kriegt man? Also API-Lamits sind da kein...
Das sind kein Problem.
Okay, und dann hast du wie viele Retweeten-Maßen überhaupt?
Also seine Tweets kriegen ja streckenweise sehr viele Retweets, oder?
Genau, also so 4000 Accounts retweeten ihn. Also ungefähr.
Und dann hast du geschaut, okay, wen retweeten die noch so?
Genau.
Und was war das Ergebnis?
Ja, auf Platz 1 war Tichichs Einblick.
Was ist das?
Ein Internetblock. Aus dem rechten Spektrum oder bürgerlich.
Bürgerlich, rechts. Ja, da kommt er gleich schon.
Außerdem, das wird man ja wohl noch sagen, Spektrum der Gesellschaft. Sagen dürfen, ja.
Das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen. Wie nennen die sich selber?
Ich glaube, bürgerlich, konservativ.
Nee, rechtskonservativ, oder? Oder rechtsliberal oder konservativ-liberal.
Oder wie auch immer diese Schattierungen von Braun genannt werden.
Also so hellbraun.
Ja, das ist die große Frage. Die selber sagen ja, sie sind Mitte immer.
Also egal, wie braun sie sind.
Ja, ist ja in der Mitte so.
Liberalkonservativ nennen wir es. Ah, Liberalkonservativ. Das liberalkonservative Meinungsmagazin.
Manche nennen es auch rechtspopulistisch.
Das sagen nur die anderen.
Die zweifelhafte Mission von Open Arms und das Doppelspiel Spaniens.
War es das jetzt schon mit der Methodik oder bist du da noch ein bisschen tiefer vorgehört?
Genau, das war so der Startpunkt. Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns die Anteile an.
Also welche haben einen hohen Prozentanteil von anderen Accounts,
die retweetet werden von Maaßen.
Und dann war die Idee, okay, dann mache ich noch eine Visualisierung von Twitter.
Da gibt es ja auch sehr viele schon und es gibt sehr viele Netzwerkvisualisierungen
und ich habe halt eine andere Form der Visualisierung gewählt,
Startpunkt von dieser Visualisierung waren aber auch Retweets und dann kann
man halt sehen auf dieser Karte auf dieser 2D-Ebene,
von Accounts, die ein ähnliches Retweet-Verhalten,
von ihren Followern praktisch haben, von den Maßen,
Okay, da müsste man sich vielleicht jetzt die Visualisierung vorstellen Ja.
Ich habe es hier gesehen Das muss man sich immer vorstellen.
Ich kann mir das auch vorstellen. Die auch alle.
Und es kam also... Post für dich. Post aus dem Hafen.
Oh, das ist, glaube ich, private Post.
Tichys Einblick. Du hast festgestellt, dass sie auch einen Tichys Einblick retweeten.
Was retweeten die noch so?
Also wir haben uns auf diese Top 25 erstmal konzentriert. Da gab es so drei große Cluster.
Also das war Tichys Einblick, dann AfD, also AfD-Politiker. und auch AfD-Nahpersonen,
zum Beispiel Erika Steinbach.
Und dann gab es noch, sie wurden bezeichnet als offen rassistische Influencer
oder auch wahlweise als Rechtsradikale, die halt eindeutig nicht mehr in diesem
liberal-bürgerlichen Spektrum zu finden sind.
Und das sind so die großen drei Gruppen.
Und dann gab es natürlich noch Leute, die irgendwie außerhalb dieser Gruppen
waren, die so eine Scharnierfunktion übernehmen, die irgendwie nicht Fleisch,
nicht Fisch, sagt man so.
Also die irgendwo so eine, auch sehr oft, also ich würde sie als weiderliche,
alte, rechtsabgewogene Männer bezeichnen. Scheiße, das ist justiziabel.
Das Wort habe ich oft gehört in letzter Zeit natürlich.
Aber die übernehmen so eine Scharnierfunktion und schieben eigentlich den Diskurs nach rechts.
Kann man aber nicht als rechtsradikal bezeichnen.
Interessieren sich nur für die gleichen Themen und...
Genau, und twittern so Sachen, die eben bei Rechten gut ankommen,
obwohl sie selber eigentlich gar nicht recht sind.
Das ist so ihre Lesart. Kann ich ja nichts dafür...
Was passiert mit meinen Inhalten, die ich mache. Also das ist ja auch ein...
Naja, klassisches, was kann ich dafür, dass meine Leser alle Nazis sind.
Genau, kann ich ja nichts dafür.
Keine Ahnung, warum die sich da für deine Äußerungen interessieren, ja.
Also habt ihr, dieses Ergebnis war dann, ist gemündet in einem Artikel auf Netzpolitik.org.
Der Titel war, glaube ich, irgendwie, die Follower Maaßens retweeten lieber
die AfD als die CDU oder so.
Ja, der Titel war, die Anhänger Rietwieden oft Rechtsradikale, aber fast nie die CDU.
Das war nämlich auch so ein Feinding, dass der erste CDUler,
der in dieser Rietwied-Liste auftaucht, ist auf Platz 82 und sonst war keiner unter den Top 100.
Und selbst dieser Platz 82 war halt von der Werteunion einer.
Das heißt, Maaßen hat halt irgendwie gekickt, man hätte ja erwartet,
okay, der Mann ist CDU, vielleicht kommen dann auch ein paar CDUler rein,
aber das war eben gar nicht so.
Ich erinnere mich noch, als der endlich zurückgetreten wurde,
dass ich mir Sorgen darüber machte, dass er jetzt halt irgendwie so ein Posterboy
der offenen Rechten wird, die dann irgendwie ihre Verschwörungstheorien weiter ausgießen können.
Und das scheint sich ja jetzt auch hier zu bewahrheiten.
Ja, also ich meine, die Interpretation dieser Daten kann eigentlich nur sein,
dass die Anhängerschaft eben doch sehr rechtslastig retweetet.
Ich liebe das, wie ihr euch ausdrückt.
Naja, wir haben irgendwie acht oder neun Schlageandrohungen bekommen,
die alle natürlich nicht gekommen sind.
Aber das ist, wir haben die Sachen auch mal über eigene Accounts laufen lassen
und das sieht dann halt nicht so rechtsradikal aus.
Genau.
Und also überraschend ist, überrascht dich das, Tim?
Also nicht.
Welcher Teil?
Das Maßen von Rechtsradikalen Nee.
Überhaupt nicht.
Links-liberalkonservativen, asylkritischen Freibürgern, Freidenkern oder sowas?
Dass mich das überrascht, dass die das tun. Das war deine Frage.
Überhaupt nicht überrascht mich das. Das war ja total absehbar,
als der dann gegangen ist.
Ich fand es schon einfach bezeichnend, wie zäh er eigentlich aus diesem System,
rausgetropft ist, wie viel da,
irgendwie noch an seinem Bein gehangen hat, um das irgendwie zu verhindern,
obwohl es eigentlich von Anfang an schon überhaupt nicht mehr haltbar war.
Und das hat er ja irgendwie auch schon gezeigt, dass da irgendwie er so eine
Rolle hat und es viele Leute gibt,
die nicht wollen, dass er diese Rolle verliert, weil da viel dranhängt.
Und als es dann doch passiert ist, war es ja klar, dass das dann eben dahingehend
auch ausgeschlachtet werden wird, so Märtyrer-Approach.
Und er sagt ja jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel anderes, als er vorher gesagt hat.
Also er packt es vielleicht in andere Worthülsen, aber so im Kern hat sich ja
an seiner Politik nichts geändert.
Ja, ich meine, da ist eine Kontinuität, aber ich glaube, das ist schon so,
Also ich meine, der twittert U-Watch,
das ist so ein rechtes Verschwörungsportal, würde ich es mal nennen.
Die Inhalte, die er verbreitet, ist nochmal ein bisschen stärker geworden,
auch wenn Maaßen schon in seiner Doktorarbeit irgendwie eben das große Asylproblem
an die Wand gemalt hat und so.
Also da gibt es eine Kontinuität, aber ich glaube, dass er jetzt natürlich nochmal deutlich anzieht.
Und was ist jetzt passiert nach der Veröffentlichung? Also eine No-News,
irgendwie Spinner, die Verschwörungstheoretiker retweeten, retweeten Georg Maaßen.
Big News. Und dann, was passiert?
Als erstes, was passiert ist, ist, dass ein paar CDUler diesen Artikel retweetet
haben. Das fanden sie interessant.
Guck mal, der ist ja bei uns, aber der macht ja nichts für uns.
Also es war so ein bisschen so eine Reaktion aus dem liberalen CDU-Spektrum.
Und dann hat es ein bisschen gedauert und dann ging halt ein 4-Tage-Shitstorm
los und man muss sagen, der war unangenehm, die können das.
Es sind aber gar nicht so viele Accounts, die das gemacht haben,
aber das ging dann halt schon...
Geht dann schon ab.
Was passiert dann so?
Naja, dann hast du die ganze Zeit, ihr könnt doch nicht kategorisieren,
ihr linksextremistischen Terroristen.
Also das ist ja eine Art Rominem, Angriffe ohne Ende und eben dann Wortspiele
mit, ha, der Filter, bei der Name ist ja schon klar, dass das alles manipuliert
ist, wenn man den Code veröffentlicht.
Genau, der wurde extra so genannt.
Wurde extra so genannt und so, da finde ich nichts anderes. Das ganze Spektrum
an rechtem Shitstorm hat uns dann getroffen.
Dann wurde in deiner beruflichen Vergangenheit gewühlt. Da gibt es ja dann auch
immer so Recherche-Asse.
Recherche, Recherche, Recherche-Asse. Ja, genau.
Google-Ergebnis 5 finden und dann groß präsentieren. als die Große.
Asse, wirklich ganz, ganz großartige Eremiten, die irgendwo in Süddeutschland
wohnen und dann sehr genau recherchieren können. Das machen die gerne.
Dafür sind die auch bekannt, dass sie das eigentlich lieber mit Frauen machen,
jungen Frauen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema, die dann so ganz krasse Sachen
herausfinden, wie zum Beispiel wo du gearbeitet hast, bevor du bei Netzpolitik.org warst.
Ja, genau. Asse, Asse. Und die drohen dann mit so Enthüllungen.
Gut zu wissen, das kommt in irgendwie ins Archiv und wird dann irgendwann als
Kompromat rausgeholt. Steht halt eh öffentlich da.
Das ist jetzt auch nichts, wofür du dich schämen müsstest, wo du gearbeitet hast.
Aber wir sagen es nicht. Wir gucken, ob ihr es rauskommt.
Mal gucken, ob ihr auch Google bis 5 lesen könnt.
Dann, naja, in so einem Fall, wenn du natürlich dann irgendwie einen Haufen
Androhungen bekommst, da haben alle dann oft wieder Klage, Strafanzeige und
dann geht man zu einem Medienrechtsanwalt, zu einem Guten und dann hat er gesagt, ja,
mach mal keine Sorgen, ich ziehe mir jetzt den Stahlhelm auf.
Und ja, dann prüft man den Text nochmal durch, guckt, hat man irgendwie Scheiße gebaut.
Ich meine, wichtig ist ja bei so Dingern immer, dass man keine falschen Tatsachenbehauptungen
macht, die sind abmahnfähig und dann gibt man eine Unterlassung und man will
natürlich keine Unterlassung von irgendwelchen Leuten bekommen, weil das ist irgendwie,
es fühlt sich nicht gut an, kostet Geld und dann haben sie gewonnen und können natürlich sagen,
haben wir doch recht und so und diese bösen Linksextremisten oder was auch immer
sie, als was sie uns bezeichnen.
Genau, bislang ist nichts gekommen. Ich vermute auch, da kommt nichts mehr und
außerdem stehen wir ganz gut
da, weil der Artikel eben keine falschen Tatsachenbehauptungen enthielt.
Ja, das ist ja vor allem auch alles direkt nachvollziehbar.
Ja, ich glaube, das große Problem ist, dass Rechte ungern als Rechte bezeichnet
werden. Und das ist halt eine Strategie der neuen Rechten.
Während irgendwie die Nazis früher gesagt haben, wir sind Nationalsozialisten,
sagen halt heute die Rechten, wir
sind die bürgerliche Mitte oder liberal-konservativ oder was auch immer.
Weil sie dadurch den Diskurs verschieben können und sagen, dieses ganze linke
Deutschland und wir sind die einzigen in der Mitte.
Die CDU hat schon immer unsere Positionen gehabt. Und da muss man eben auch
ran, wenn man eine freie und offene Gesellschaft verteidigen will,
muss man eben genau zeigen, dass die nicht in der Mitte stehen.
Wolltest du das noch sagen?
Geht denn das jetzt noch weiter? Ist das Ding jetzt schon irgendwie abgeschlossen
und wir reden jetzt hier über kalten Kaffee?
Dass man sich rechte Strukturen anschaut, ich habe das ja öfter auf Netzpolitik.org
schon gemacht, die AfD untersucht, bei denen haben wir lauter so inoffizielle
Unterstützer-Accounts gefunden, dann auch den Typen in Münster,
der das Ganze gemanagt hat und Leute, die uns gesagt haben in der Recherche,
Also ja, ich wurde bezahlt, um zu retweeten. Die machen so eine Scheinriesennummern.
Ich finde schon, dass man sich das anschauen muss, eben was,
wie die rechten Strategien sind.
Und mit offenen Daten das eben auch zu machen.
Die Sache, wie die weitergeht, weiß nicht. Ich finde schon, dass man da dranbleiben
kann. Und ich finde natürlich auch diese Scharnierleute interessant.
Also die haben natürlich den meisten Wirbel gemacht.
Von denen gab es auch welche, die würde ich nicht als rechtsradikal bezeichnen.
Das haben wir in der Klarstellung auch nochmal gesagt.
Das sind nicht alles Rechtsradikale, aber die sind natürlich extrem wichtig,
weil sie den Diskurs verschieben.
Und die sind extrem laut und die sind eben vernetzt und verwurzelt rein in die
Welt, in verschiedene konservative Medien rein.
Und das macht sie halt auch so gefährlich für den politischen Diskurs.
Ich finde die meisten, die sich am meisten beschweren, dass sie da aufgeführt
werden, könnte man ja mal dieselbe Analyse. draufwerfen.
Ja, also im Shitstorm zu stehen macht halt nicht so viel Spaß,
aber andererseits sollte man sich davon nicht abschrecken lassen,
weil das ist ja genau die Strategie davon.
Und ich glaube, man will den Shitstorm untersuchen, der so funktioniert.
Immer so jetzt von so eins bis zehn, wie shitstormig war der Storm?
Für Verhältnisse bei Netzpolitik.org war der schon ordentlich.
Ist jetzt nicht so alltäglich, dass wir so angegangen werden.
Ja, mach mal eine Nummer dran. Von 1 bis 10. 5 ist so der Durchschnitts-Shitstorm.
Ich glaube, er war ja contained in dieser rechten Blase.
Der hat es ja nicht rausgeschafft, so richtig aus Twitter.
Deswegen würde ich ihn nicht so hoch, aber er war jetzt persönlich schon anstrengend.
Aber die haben ja schon auch einige Artikel geschrieben. Also ich habe dann
so in irgendwelchen Seiten, die ich nicht kenne, haben sich dann überlegt,
dann nochmal ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit draufgießen zu müssen,
dass sie da jetzt irgendwie analysiert wurden.
Ich glaube, was sie am meisten gestört hat, ist, dass die FAZ quasi den Artikel
übernommen hat und darüber auch geschrieben hat.
Und dann haben sie sich auf die FAZ gestürzt, weil das ist natürlich für so,
wenn du den Diskurs nach rechts verschieben willst und ein konservatives Medium irgendwie,
haut da auch drauf, das fanden die ganz schlimm, weil dann aus eigenen Reihen
quasi, oder was sie als eigene Reihen sehen, angegriffen werden, haben sie die FAZ, ach,
FAZ ist wie die Taz und so. Linkes Schmierblatt.
Den Tweet rahmen die sich bei der Taz aber ein.
Ich habe noch einen Artikel gefunden, Johannes, da war wurde irgendwie so eine
Methodenkritik versucht, der ich auch nicht so ganz folgen konnte,
wo also gesagt wurde, deine Analyse wäre irgendwie...
Also ich habe ja den Code veröffentlicht, schon gleich beim ersten Artikel,
um dann auch zu zeigen, okay, ihr könnt das einfach genauso ausführen.
Das hat tatsächlich auch ein AfD-Wähler gemacht auf einen CDU-Politiker.
Auf Rupskolins, genau. Das sieht auch sehr schön aus, ein ganz normales bürgerliches
Spektrum, was man da so sieht.
Genau, aber es wurde alles kritisiert, was man kritisieren kann an der Analyse.
Und ich habe diesen Blogpost auch gelesen, aber es ist halt Fake News.
Keine Ahnung, ich kann da gerne auch eine Stellungnahme noch zu machen. Also du hast gesagt.
Alles wurde kritisiert, was man kritisieren kann. Heißt das,
diese Kritik war valide, weil ich habe, was ich da streckenweise gelesen habe,
schien mir nicht deine Aussage zu sein.
Nee, also es ist nicht valide. Also natürlich, ich habe auch drei E-Mails bekommen,
mit sehr gutem Feedback, so, wo man auch sagt, okay, man kann Sachen auch anders
machen, aber bis jetzt wurde jetzt noch nicht gezeigt, dass da jetzt irgendein
Fehler drin steckt, weil das ja auch keine No-News ist, also das ist ja auch
überhaupt nicht überraschend, das ist halt die Realität.
Also natürlich muss man vorsichtig sein, so eine Infografik,
das ist jetzt nicht die richtige Realität und versuche das natürlich runterzubrechen,
aber ich würde schon sagen, dass es der Wahrheit so gut wie geht,
also schon nahe kommt. So sehe ich das.
Ich meine, viel Streit war glaube ich gar nicht, also die Methodik haben sich
zwar alles angegangen und konnten da aber nichts irgendwie,
dran rumkritteln und eher die Interpretationen, weil ihr habt ja gesagt,
das ist dann die und die Blase und ihr nennt das so und so und das ist halt
dieses Ding, ich bin es auch immer ein bisschen leid, so dieses 50,
Farbabstufungen von Braun immer zu machen,
was da eingefordert wird. Also ich finde es...
Ich kann auch Sachen benennen, wie sie sind.
Ich meine jetzt so, im Datensalat noch ein bisschen rumzustochern,
ist ja sicherlich ein Sport, der nicht aussterben wird.
Was würdet ihr denn so anderen Leuten, die ähnliche Projekte ins Auge fassen, so raten?
Also von der Herangehensweise, vom Start weg vielleicht und auch so innerhalb
eines solchen Prozesses.
Also wenn man jetzt quasi mal die Nadel in einem anderen Heuhaufen versucht
zu finden, beziehungsweise hier ist ja eigentlich mehr der Heuhaufen, den man gefunden hat.
Gibt es da so Tipps?
Ja, also ich würde schon sagen, man sollte den Artikel so schreiben,
dass man ihn sehr schwer falsch verstehen kann.
Weil, also das ist schon auch wichtig, dass wenn Leute halt nur die Überschrift
und da eine Grafik lesen, dass die Leute halt nicht komplett ausflippen.
Weil wenn man den Artikel komplett liest, dann ist der voll korrekt,
aber das ist halt schon eine Überspitzung, auch die Überschrift zum Beispiel.
Ja gut, aber ich meine jetzt so, was auch die Methodik betrifft,
also du hast ja gesagt, Code veröffentlichen ist sicherlich schon mal ein guter Rat.
Ja, also man hätte jetzt im Nachhinein, wir waren ja beide überrascht von der
ganzen Resonanz, weil es ja für uns auch keine News war, also wir hätten nie
gedacht, dass sich so viele Leute dafür interessieren.
Ich hätte den Artikel doppelt so lange gemacht und dann noch mehr erklärt,
also das würde ich jetzt im Nachhinein machen, aber kann man jetzt nicht mehr zurückdrehen.
Ja, Linus ich glaube, wir können uns bedanken bei Johannes und bei Markus,
vielen Dank für die Ausführung,
Wir haben nämlich noch mehr Gäste für euch und wo seid ihr?
Viktor und Sophia, ihr könnt jetzt mal zu uns kommen.
Ihr müsst euch vorher überlegen, wer wo sitzen möchte.
Und da sind sie auch schon. Hallo, super. Einfach jetzt los geht's.
Genau, und jetzt... Hallo.
Ja, wir haben uns erst heute so richtig kennengelernt, aber für euch ist das ja nicht neu.
Wie oft warst du schon auf einem Camp oder Kongress oder ähnlichen Veranstaltungen?
Auf den letzten zwei Kongressen, aber das ist mein erstes Camp.
Wir sind eine Gruppe und wir sind hier alle zusammen auch hingekommen.
Ich bin hier, seit ich in der digitalen Freiheit bin.
Die hat Victor nämlich gegründet.
Genau, da hast du es mir schon vorweggenommen. Ihr seid zwei von wie vielen Leuten?
Das wechselt. Größenordnung.
Das ist ja immer so bei so Gruppierungen, dass das irgendwie so nach außen.
Es gibt Menschen, die machen ab und zu was. Es gibt Menschen, die sind sehr oft da.
Bloß nicht zu genau sein.
Also ich würde sagen 15. Ja, okay. Plus erweitert das Umfeld.
Erweitert der Freundeskreis.
Okay, aber das ist schon mehr als jetzt eine WG.
Ja, größer als eine WG.
Und das nennt sich digitale Freiheit. Und seit wann gibt es das?
Ich würde mal sagen, 2017. Sommer 2017 sind das zwei Jahre. Ja, zwei Jahre.
Und warum gibt es das? Ja, warum gibt es die digitale Freiheit?
Das ist eigentlich eine lustige Geschichte. Und zwar...
Also es gibt ja auch verschiedene andere, ich sag mal, netzpolitisch agierende
Organisationen in Berlin.
Es gibt auch schon alles.
Es gibt auch schon alles. Ja, es gibt auch schon alles abgedeckt.
Bis auf unsere kleine Nische, wie wir finden.
Und zwar tatsächlich sind einige der Leute, die dann am Anfang bei uns dazugekommen
sind, haben die gleiche Geschichte durchgemacht von, dass sie irgendwie auf
der Suche waren nach irgendeiner, ich sag mal, Gruppierung, irgendeiner Organisation,
Organisationen, die, ich sag mal,
da irgendwie sich engagiert, da irgendwie arbeitet und Überwachung doof findet.
Also versucht zu erklären, dass irgendwie Privatsphäre gut ist und Überwachung nicht so.
Und das hatte ich das einmal durch, dass ich irgendwie quasi versucht habe,
Organisationen zu finden in Berlin, die das tun, wo man einfach so als Externer,
wenn man niemanden kennt, einfach dazukommen kann,
und das ist mir nicht richtig gelungen also irgendwie, ich bin bei vielen mal
irgendwie dazugekommen, aber das hat irgendwie nicht gepasst,
auch jetzt sagen wir einfach Menschen in meiner Altersgruppe,
und tatsächlich habe ich dann irgendwann so ein paar Leute an der TU,
gefunden gehabt und die hatten jeweils auch ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht,
dass denen irgendwie auch so dieses ich sag mal irgendwie,
junge Menschen, die da irgendwie was machen wollen, hatten die nicht gefunden
und dann dachten wir so, hey cool, da haben wir jetzt ein paar Leute, dann gründen wir da was.
Oder quasi gründen klingt so formal, setzen wir uns zusammen.
Ging es dir denn auch so?
Ich habe angefangen zu studieren und dachte mir, okay, jetzt studiere ich und
will mich auch irgendwie politisch engagieren.
Und ich hatte relativ vage so die Ahnung, ja, ich glaube, so Privatsphäre,
damit möchte ich mich mehr auseinandersetzen.
Und dann habe ich diese sympathischen jungen Menschen gesehen in dieser Gruppe,
wo man nicht so wahnsinnig viel technisches Know-how gleich mitbringen musste,
sondern wo man einfach sich zusammengesetzt hat.
Und keine Ahnung, wir haben Leute dabei, die studieren Soziologie und Philosophie
und Grafikdesign oder Jura.
Und wo man dann zusammensitzt und eben schaut, okay, was haben eigentlich diese.
Ganzen Maßnahmen, Staatstrojaner oder Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so weiter.
Was haben die eigentlich für Einflüsse auf die Gesellschaft und ich fand halt
total angenehm, dass irgendwie, was die Jungs und Mädels da geschaffen haben,
es war so eine Stimmung, dass niemand sich irgendwie schämen musste,
irgendwas zu fragen, weil es ja Themen sind, mit denen man sich nicht automatisch
die ganze Zeit beschäftigt und,
genau, so bin ich dann da geblieben, also es war die erste Orga,
zu der ich gekommen bin und ich glaube nicht einfach geblieben,
weil es da sehr nett war und genau. So ging es mir dabei.
Also in eurem Twitter-Bio heißt es Aktionen und Partys für mehr Datenschutz
und informationelle Selbstbestimmung.
Jetzt bin ich ja gespannt. Was für Aktionen und was für Partys habe ich verpasst?
Wurzere Darkrooms als bei unseren Partys.
Wie macht man eine Party für mehr Datenschutz? Nicht auf Facebook announcen?
Ja, das schließe ich.
Wir waren hier raus aus der Zielgruppe.
Wir sind zum Beispiel ganz bewusst auf Facebook und wir sind auch gerade dabei,
unseren Instagram-Account zuzulegen. So schrecklich wir das alles finden.
Aber noch viel wichtiger finden wir halt irgendwie da, wo die Menschen sind, irgendwie diese Sachen,
hinzutragen, irgendwie das zu erklären.
Ja, wo die Old Farts halt auch sich nicht mehr hinbewegen, weil das irgendwie nicht mehr ihr Ding ist.
Stimmt ja jetzt auch nicht, dass wir die einzigen jungen Leute sind,
die sich für da anschauen.
Ja, genau. Das wollte ich damit ja auch nicht sagen. Ich tummel mich nicht auf Facebook.
Ich habe da zwar so einen Proxy-Account quasi, den ich so benutze,
damit ich da mal reingucken kann, wie es da so aussieht und dann mache ich das
wieder zu. Aber benutzen tue ich das für gar nicht.
Genau, also um kurz zu erklären, Partys und Datenschutz, wir haben das tatsächlich auch mal ausprobiert.
Irgendwie, wir hatten ein Open Air hinter unserer Uni, wo es dann so eine Workshop-Ecke
gab und dann gab es so eine Aktion, dass du, wenn du eine verschlüsselte Mail
an die Bar schickst, kriegst du ein Freibier und so.
Das ist mal eine Kryptoparty. Ja.
Das wollen die jetzt hier auch haben.
Das wird teuer.
Es stellte sich dann aber heraus, dass so Partyvölkchen spätestens ab einem
gewissen Beschallert zustanden.
Spätestens nach der dritten verschlüsselten Bild.
Ja, genau. Schon dann doch eher interessierter an der Musik waren als an unseren
super tollen Workshop-Tischen.
Und wir hatten dann doch Franz Fies aufgehängt
und so dekoriert mit so selbstsachsgräbsgebastelten Überwachungskameras.
Und wir machen immer noch Partys, weil viele von uns, also es liegt uns irgendwie,
aber ich habe mittlerweile so ein bisschen die Hoffnung aufgegeben mit Partys
jetzt politisch irgendwie großartig irgendwie Menschen was beibringen zu können,
sondern, ja also ich finde, man darf nicht so einen edukatorischen Ansatz haben
bei Partys, sondern viele Menschen werden da dann trotzdem hingehen,
einfach weil sie Bock haben auf geile Musik und das finde ich auch okay.
Der Stil kommt nicht. Ich habe auch mal versucht, den Leuten zu erklären,
sie müssten anders tanzen, das kam auch überhaupt nicht weg.
Tanz doch mal anders.
Das ist schon ganz gut. Probieren wir mal das. Okay, und was für Aktionen bleiben
da noch, wenn die Partys wegfallen?
Fotoaktionen zum Beispiel.
Foto.
Also, was wir uns dann manchmal überlegen, zum Beispiel, was jetzt total aktuell
in unserem Kontext war in Berlin, wo wir sind, war die Gesichtserkennung am Südkreuz.
Und dann haben wir uns lange überlegt, wie können wir eigentlich diese Problematik,
was bedeutet eigentlich intelligente Videoüberwachung, wenn sie ausgeweitet
werden soll auf ganz Deutschland, was bedeutet das eigentlich.
Und dann haben wir halt lange überlegt, wie wir das so bildlich darstellen können
und haben uns dann irgendwie beklebt und haben unseren riesigen selbstgebastelten
Kamerakopf und unseren selber ausgehöhlten Monitor,
den wir irgendwie davor die ganze Stadt geschleppt haben, der irre schwer war,
weil da noch so lauter Scheiß drin war, den wir dann rausgetan haben.
Und haben uns diese Sachen aufgesetzt und sind da irgendwie hingefahren ans
Südkreuz und haben geschaut,
okay, wie können wir diese Datenverarbeitung irgendwie darstellen mit dieser
Kamera und diesem Monitor und den beklebten Leuten, die irgendwie demonstrieren.
Und genau, also die Beklebung war so ein Skelett, dass man quasi durchgescannt
wird und genau, haben uns dann eben überlegt mit den verschiedenen Leuten,
die da eben sitzen und die ganz verschiedene Inputs haben und ganz verschiedene visuelle Ideen auch,
wie wir das am besten machen und das war jetzt zum Beispiel eine unserer letzten
Aktionen, unserer Fotoaktion.
Und wie ist das angekommen?
Naja, auf Netzpolitik.org.
Ich meine bei den Leuten vor Ort so, am Südkreuz.
Genau, also da sind Leute gekommen, es kommen eigentlich immer Leute,
auch als wir unser riesen Keine-Upload-Filter-Banner vor der CDU-Zentrale aufgestellt
haben, kommen Leute und dann fängt man an zu reden und erstaunlich viel Gutes,
erstaunlich viel, dass die Leute kommen, ja super, dass ihr das macht,
finde ich auch kacke. ja.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass das jetzt Leute sind, die dadurch irgendwie so einen
finalen Kick bekommen oder sich in dem Moment einfach nur kurz erleichtern,
weil sie sich selber nicht trauen
oder zu wenig Mut haben und dann aber vielleicht auch nichts ändern?
Also das ist ja mal so eine Frage der Wahrnehmung.
Naja, ich hoffe halt, dass wir irgendwie das Thema ein bisschen mehr in die
Öffentlichkeit pushen können dadurch. Das ist ja auch irgendwie das erklärte Ziel.
Da habt ihr euch ja noch was anderes ausgedacht und zwar jetzt rede ich mal
ganz konkret von euch beiden, weil ihr,
Eine Band gegründet.
Ja.
Also ihr seid die Band, ja, du, Sophia und Viktor und ihr nennt euch,
sehr schön, Systemabsturz.
Welches System wollt ihr denn zum Absturz bringen und wie geht ihr denn da vor? Unklar.
Also, das klingt jetzt vielleicht böser als es ist. Wir sind trotzdem sehr demokratieüberzeugt
und so und wir wollen keine Systeme zum Absturzen.
Das ist ja ein Absturz. Das ist ja halt Sturz.
Das ist sowieso sehr wichtig.
Wir haben tatsächlich so, am Anfang war unser Gag, dass wir aus Datenschutzgründen
immer unter anderem Namen gespielt haben und dann einfach so vor jedem Auftritt
unseren neuen Namen überlegt haben.
Kenne ich auch so einen Typen, der das gerne macht.
Ich habe da auch gemerkt, dass er damit nicht berühmt fällt.
Irgendwann kommt der Punkt, wo du merkst, Mensch, das ist doch ganz schön kompliziert.
Und es war eigentlich erst jetzt für so, irgendwie, hey, können wir beim Camp
spielen, hey, können wir bei der Netzpolitik-Konferenz Afterparty spielen.
Dass wir uns überlegt haben, oh, das ist vielleicht doch ganz praktisch,
wenn irgendwie der gleiche Name so zweimal auftaucht.
Wir wissen immer noch nicht, ich glaube, aktuell ist es einfach Systemabsturz.
Ich glaube, so Namensänderungs und Pseudonyme behalten wir uns auf jeden Fall vor.
Aber, genau, und das kam dann irgendwann mal, es war einfach einer von vielen Namen.
Damit gelingt es euch jetzt wieder die Inhalte in die Party zurück zu bringen?
Ja, also mehr so, ich weiß nicht, ob wir die reine Partymusik sind und wie gesagt,
wir sind ja noch, wir machen das ja noch nicht lange, wir sind da relativ frisch mit.
Im Idealfall schaffen wir es damit natürlich irgendwie Dinge zu kommunizieren
an Menschen, die uns sonst nicht zugehört hätten, aber das ist bis jetzt auch
noch nicht groß passiert.
Am Anfang haben wir auch versucht, Liebeslieder zu schreiben,
aber es hat auch einfach nicht so gut geklappt.
Wir haben dann auch gemerkt, Datenschutz liegt uns ein bisschen mehr.
Wir haben uns schon mehr Gedanken dazu gemacht.
Datenschutz statt verfügbar.
Ich love you, but I've chosen Datenschutz.
Dementsprechend heißt das Genre, was ihr jetzt vertritt, Datenschutz-Elektropunk.
Das finde ich auch mal eine ganz klare Ansage. ich muss sagen,
ich hatte so beim Anhören totale Flashbacks, weil da einfach eine ganze Menge
so von den 80er Jahren wieder auf mich zugeflogen kam.
Wir sind da vorhin auch nochmal so ein bisschen durch den Zeitstrahl gereist.
Hier werden die Parallelen durchaus aufgefallen sein.
Und ich finde das ja gut, weil ehrlich gesagt, dieses Camp und überhaupt die
ganze Szene hat ja wirklich eine ganze Menge Kram hervorgebracht.
Man läuft hier irgendwie um jede Ecke und irgendwie alles wird gebastelt,
alles wird gemacht, wird getan.
Aber so Musik, mal ehrlich, also abgesehen davon, dass wir uns hier immer so
ein bisschen mit dem Techno anrauschen, ist sozusagen originär.
Jetzt aus dem Umfeld heraus ist noch sehr überschaubar, sag ich mal, das Angebot.
Wir haben ja immer wieder ein paar schöne Clips und spielen immer alles gerne, was prima passt.
Aber ich denke, das ist auch ein Zeichen einer Weiterentwicklung.
Weil ich meine, welche Revolution kommt ohne ihre eigene Musik aus?
Ja, also insofern finde ich das schon mal ganz gut.
Dann wären wir jetzt, glaube ich, an dem Punkt, dass die beiden spielen können.
Oder? Genau, weil wir werden nämlich auch diese Sendung mit einem Bonus-Track,
enden und haben die beiden gebeten, ein Stück aus ihrem Repertoire zu spielen.
Wenn ihr dann Lust auf mehr habt, dann habt ihr die Gelegenheit,
heute Abend um 22.30 Uhr, in etwa, also wie das so ist mit den Terminen auf
dem Camp, hinten im Graffel-Village, da gibt es dann die...
In Graffel Village gibt es dann die volle Packung. Aber ich glaube, ihr seid morgen.
Auch noch mal hier, oder? Da wird das dann nicht ganz so leise sein.
Nö, leise ist es ja auch nicht geplant.
Morgen um 21.30 Uhr hier.
Genau, ihr braucht noch ein bisschen Platz hier.
Und im Graffel jetzt heute um 22.30 Uhr.
Soll ich euch noch ein bisschen Platz machen? Reicht das?
Wollen wir noch ganz schnell Termine machen?
Ja, mach mal Termine. Bevor du jetzt.
Hier wieder eine Viertelstunde umbaust.
Ich baue nicht um, ich räume nur ab.
Ach so.
Sprich, ich höre dich. Ich bin voll dabei. Du müsstest die Terminmelodie kurz machen.
Oder kannst du die kurz spielen, Victor?
Nee, nee, nee, ich kann das schon machen.
Das ist kein Problem, wenn das überhaupt...
Das ist, warum ich Nidwane gegründet habe. Ich habe letztlich keinen Lieb.
Am Freitag, dem 23.08. 23 Uhr gibt es in der Chemistry Lounge Dschunkelmusik.
Am Samstag, um 20.45 Uhr War mir was falsch gemacht?
Das ist völlig okay.
Am Samstag um 20.45 Uhr gibt es hier auf dieser Bühne die Freakshow.
Im Anschluss hier auf dieser Bühne gibt es Dschunkelmusik. Wer hätte damit rechnen können?
Eure beiden Termine waren heute um 22.30 Uhr im Geraffe und morgen um 21.30 Uhr hier.
Und die Django Girls machen am 5.
Oktober einen Programmierworkshop für Einsteigerinnen mit Python und Django
für Frauen und for free in Berlin.
Der Ort wird noch bekannt gegeben, aber der Anmeldeschluss ist der 18.09.
Das heißt, da solltet ihr euch zeitnah anmelden. Wenn ihr erste Schritte in
Python machen wollt, könnt ihr das nämlich auch mit dem Cardio-Batch machen.
Das ist hier der perfekte Einstieg.
Und dann geht es direkt weiter mit Django und dann ist das Start-Up auch schon das nächste große Ding.
Das waren die Termine.
Super, dann wolltest du noch Danke sagen?
Dann wollte ich noch Danke sagen. Und zwar Danke sage ich an Michael,
Dennis, Christian und Dr.
No und alle, die heute hier waren und das Three-Headed Monkey Village.
Hallo. Oh, schön. Und damit... Ich glaube, der Tisch muss da weg.
Genau. Damit sagen wir jetzt Tschüss. Das war's mit Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Und jetzt gibt's noch Systemabsturz. Tschüss.
Okay.
Wollt ihr sitzen? Wollt ihr stehen? Ja, steht mal auf. Das ist ganz schrecklich.
Vor sitzenden Menschen. Genau.
Ganz langsam mit dem Play. Wir müssen ja noch grundlegende Sachen klären. Achso, genau.
Wenn ich sag, ihr wart mal drei Tage wach.
Nee, nochmal. Ihr wart mal drei Tage Nicht Kontrolle, verdächtig.
Auf deinen Partys läuft nur Krach. Verdächtig. So und jetzt alle.
Du warst mal drei Tage wach.
Verdächtig. Auf deinen Partys läuft nur Krach. Verdächtig.
Sehr gut. Kommt ruhig noch ein bisschen, also hier ist ja ganz viel Platz.
Der schreit ja gerade dazu danach, dass ihr hier irgendwie euch hinstellt.
Genauso macht man das bei Konzerten. Super. Danke.